in this video we'll be talking about DNA
gyes so here are the key points
regarding DNA gyes it's a bacterial
enzyme which is involved in DNA
replication and DNA repair it belongs to
type two Topo isomerized family of
protein already the name suggest it sort
of like modify the topology of the DNA
it introduces negative super coils into
the DNA to relieve torsional strain
during replication or even the process
of
transcription it's important to note
that gyes Inhibitors are widely used so
gyes Inhibitors are several antibiotics
such as
fluroquinolone namely ciprofloxacine
which can actually inhibit the DNA gyes
enzyme to prevent the bacterial growth
because without this particular enzyme
activity there is positive super coil
which accumulates this disrupts the DNA
replication in bacteria now let's talk
about what is the super coiling problem
imagine you are holding a rope one side
you are holding it and from Another Side
you are trying to unwind it but due to
the torsion that is already there it is
super difficult to separate it properly
when you start separating it after a
point of time it would wind up within
itself this is the super coiling problem
and that is actually faced by the eoli
because eoli has huge amount of DNA and
in order to pack it properly within the
small volume it has to Super coil the
DNA and it's essential for
eoli now there are specific enzymes
which can unwind the DNA during
processes like transcription and
replication and that is super important
for this biological process to occur
there are category of topoisomer enzyme
which can relieve the stress okay this
is a bacterial nucleoid where you can
see the these are the DNA loops and
basically these kind of DNA Loops can
are super coiled eventually the double
uh Helix actually coils upon itself if
one strand of these double helix is cut
then the DNA would lose up and it would
dissipate the tension and this kind of
things are done by topoisomerase class
enzymes DNA gyas is actually topoisomer
type 2
enzyme because it Cleaves both the
strand of DNA it introduce a double
strand brake and pass the Strand through
this kind of
loop so this is basically a portion of
the loop where two sides of the loop are
in different color this is how DNA GES
recognize one section of the double
stranded DNA it introduces a double
stranded DNA break always look at the
black strand then it pass this
particular red strand through this
particular Groove
and forms a particular twist and this is
how it
introduces a negative super coil in this
DNA so the job of DNA G is to introduce
a negative super coil in the
DNA and this kind of underwound DNA is
really important because negatively
super coiled DNA is essential for
transcription or replication process so
this is the structural details of the
particular enzy DNA gyes and these data
is obtained from the published extra
crystallographic structure and those
kind of co- crystallized structural
transients help us to understand how the
enzyme possibly work so here you can see
there are two major uh subunits guide a
and guide B note the guide B is the blue
one guide a is the yellow one and so
this is how it works so initially when
the DNA binds there is a ATP hydrolysis
ATP hydrolysis dimerize the GU B domain
eventually two molecule of ATP binds to
this particular enzyme in the GU B
subunit then there is a segment of the
DNA which is known as T segment or the
transfer segment it starts passing
through the uh enzyme and
move note that the other guide a acts as
a cutter so it cuts and introduce double
stranded brick in the DNA and this is
how it would be easily passing another
strand through this Gap it's important
to note that how these DNA cutting
happens it turns out there are specific
tyrine residues which has nucleophilic
sources so nucleophilic attack is the
mechanism by which the DNA is cut so it
forms a transient DNA enzyme hybrid
which later on gets
changed so from a clinical perspective
it's important to know that it's
important to note that fluroquinolones
are group of antibiotics that inhibit
DNA GES they act by binding the a
subunit of DNA GES and they allow the
enzyme to cleave the DNA but doesn't
allow it to repair it so there are DNA
double stranded bricks which would
eventually in an unrepaired state would
eliminate the bacteria some example of
flurin loans are ciprofloxacine lyine
Norine alosine Etc so I hope this video
was informative and useful if you like
this video give it a quick thumbs up
don't forget to like share and subscribe
you can support our Channel using PTM
PayPal or UPI see you in next
[Applause]
video